in 2009 he won the the Huddle report it
is a NFL draft competition graded by
draft experts and he did this in his
dorm room and he won this competition
because then later he worked for a
professional sports team working on
their draft where the draft he worked on
was declared by many illustrations as
the best draft in the league by the of
the entire NFL
so he did this for fantasy and they did
it in real life everyone please welcome
Mike today I'm here to talk to you about
the work we do at NFL Nick Shen stats my
name is Mike band I'm the senior
research and analytics manager for NFL
next gen stats and today I'm going to
talk about the many models in production
at next gen stats
so this will be the fourth year uh the
fourth time I'm spoken at the New York R
conference and each time I've sort of
updated the story of the next gen stats
world when I first talked at the New
York R conference in 2019 we had one
model in production and that's the model
that I talked about completion
probability
today we're going to go through the many
models that are now in production 15 in
total and we're going to take a a quick
journey through what is next-gen stats
the evolution of our toolbox
and then the many models in production
so let's start with the question what is
next-gen stats
next-gen stats is the real time player
tracking data collection team
we are we are the NFL and so the NFL
owns our uh owns the property and we
distribute our data uh for a variety of
reasons so it's uh for broadcast use for
the teams themselves and for the league
office to make the game better
so what you could imagine is we have
RFID sensors in every player's shoulder
pads tracking their X Y speed Direction
all of these data points every tenth of
a second for every play on the field
this equates to millions of data points
per game that we have to munge and find
data for
so with all of this data we are able to
create a significant number of metrics
and as you can see on the on the left
that is a play that we can recreate on a
two-dimensional dots with our data so
the play on the left is the longest pass
completed in the next gen stats era
since 2016 and I'll go deeper into this
play on how we can break down some of
the stats within it
so who's using next-gen stats data well
the first we got to start with the
broadcast and how do we engage fans with
better data and more valid metrics so
this is going beyond the box score of
yards and touchdowns and tackles to more
complex metrics like the ones we're
going to talk about today
all 32 teams are using this data whether
it's picking players in the draft or
free agency whether it's finding uh
finding the weaknesses in your defense
whether it's finding tendencies in your
own team
they're trying to use this player
tracking data to make their team better
to make better decisions when it comes
to their roster and overall make their
make their processes in season and out
of season more efficient
and finally the league office so we have
an office in New York and we have an
office in La the LA office is more of
the NFL Media Group where an extern
stats is located at the New York League
office that group is doing way more work
to try to make the game better through
rules or player safety initiatives Tom
Bliss and Ali Blake are both in the
studio audience today and it's been
great to to see the league office really
leverage the player tracking technology
to make the game better
so before we dive into all the models I
would love to take you through a history
of the evolution of the stats toolbox at
next gen stats
so we started with a question
what stats can we create if we have
player tracking data every tenth of a
second for every play
well
our inaugural season which was the 2015
season when we finally had centers in
every Stadium we were able to create
basic stats like top speed distance
traveled or participation like how many
snaps did a player play
before that that was done by Human by
manual human data labeling in the
stadium every game now we can use
technology to say who's on the field
but then we sort of had to get more
advanced with our toolbox we tried to
look into what can we create if we take
the raw tracking data merge it with our
traditional football stats we call it
gsis
and how can we then extract more
meaningful logic based stats this would
be Airy Arts which would be the distance
of past travels downfield or separation
which would measure the receiver's
distance to the nearest cornerback all
of these stats help us get a lot of more
advanced stats without having to need
machine learning modeling
but then over the years and especially
with the help of the open source
competition the Big Data Bowl we have
dived into a much more advanced set of
Statistics that cover a variety of
different aspects of the game of
football
so what we started with was speed and
distance now we have measures like
completion probability expected yards
coverage classification wind probability
we can even say whether or not a team
should go for it on fourth down
and today
we have now 15 models active models in
production that we have to maintain now
we have different questions to ask how
often do we retrain our models is our
architecture as efficient as possible
are the dependencies that our models
built on good enough or up to date all
of these questions mean that we're not
only creating new models we have to
maintain our existing ones
and so today I'm going to keep diving
I'm going to go through our list
of the many models in production at
next-gen stats
so what you're about to see is an
intimidating slide it's got all of the
stats currently in production so we can
start with completion probability what's
the odds of a pass being completed or
expected rushing yards in Yak which
estimates the number of yards that a a
ball carrier would gain let's start with
a simpler list
so these five stats I'm going to go
through a little bit more detail talk
about the model types the training set
the features that go into it and all the
little decisions that we made and we'll
also give examples of what it looks like
in actual broadcast
now as I go through each of these models
there's key assumptions and
considerations that we have to take
account for the first these models have
to generate predictions in real time or
near real time so after the play is
processed after the play ends we have to
be able to hit the model and create an
aggregate or create a result a
prediction
two the model must be explainable or at
least exp or at least the problem
matches our intuition what do I mean
well if we can use tabular data to to
solve a problem we will because we can
understand the features that go into it
and certainly your football expertise is
going to dictate what features you end
up engineering out of the pro the player
tracking data but if we do use neural
networks and deep learning techniques
does the problem match the match the the
problem statement does the architecture
match the problem that's the key to if
we were to use deep learning and I'll go
through some of those uh those neural
networks that we have in production how
can we best understand what the model is
doing
and third the model must pass the eye
test this is probably the most important
part especially for our researchers and
analysts who have to sell this data and
say that this stat matters because and
the only way to get football people to
really grab onto a stat is if it makes
sense when you see it so when you see a
past that's very difficult to complete
and it says the model says 75 percent
you know something's wrong in the data
even if the scoring evaluation metrics
are good
so we do a lot of human labeling or
human relabeling to identify what
perhaps could be the issue in the model
so let's start with completion
probability the question that this model
is trying to answer what are the chances
a given pass will be completed based off
of the difficulty of the throw
so the model we used is an XG boost
model
the features that go into it you can see
on the right in the with the chat plot
so we have how far the ball traveled in
the air the separation the receiver had
from the nearest offender when the ball
arrived how much how fast the
quarterback and the receiver were going
the location of the of the quarterback
when he threw the football and the
receiver when they threw the football
and much more
we had a Target variable of a Boolean if
the pass was completed one and if the
pass was incomplete zero
and we use the 2018 to 2021 Seasons as a
training set and then we would use the
22 regular season as the test and 22
postseason as the validation set
so what can we do with this data
in real time
so you can see on the right this is a
play example of one of the longest
passes in the NFL over the last 10 years
so the past this play happened in the
Carolina Panthers Atlanta Falcons game
at the end of the game
Philip Walker or the Panthers needed a
touchdown they were down by six it's 20
seconds left and you can see Philip
Walker rolls out to his left and finds
DJ Moore downfield for a 62-yard
touchdown
our model said that the completion
probability was 11.5 percent the fourth
lowest completion probability of any
completion during the season
and you can see the leading Factor air
distance
67.6 yards in the air as the crow flies
you could say from the point the
quarterback threw the ball to the moment
the receiver uh the ball arrived at the
receiver the ball traveled 67.6 yards in
the air so not only can we use
completion probability to contextualize
a play but we can also break down the
features that go into it
now we'll talk about expected yards
estimate the number of yards a ball
carrier would gain from the moment they
receive the ball
and within expected yards we've found
that we need separate models for every
separate situation
the reason
is because the distributions of outcomes
are different for these different
situations so whatever you train on
those distributions you can see on the
left versus the right in that graph the
distributions are going to give you
different results so if we created a
single model for both kick return and
punt return plays we would have a biased
model
so what we have for expected yards we
have different models for each group we
have five in total expected rushing
yards on a handoff
expected yards after catch we also have
expected rushing yards on a scramble so
when a quarterback tries to scramble
from the pocket we can measure that that
prediction we have expected yards after
catch which represents the receiver once
they catch a ball how many yards will
they gain and then last year we launched
expected return yards which predicts
kick and putt return yardage
as you can see the architecture we used
was a convolutional neural network
and we use a technique called pooling
where you take the X Y the speed
direction and you create relative you
create a matrix of every player relative
to every other player on the field
and this architecture was actually
created uh for by the big datable
winners in 2019 when they won the
expected rushing yards competition and
they they were two Austrian data
scientists who had the thought of how
can we simplify this problem a DOT has
to get from here to there
with a lot of things in the way it's
almost like a video game you could say
and so they created this technique they
didn't engine they didn't have to
engineer a single feature so when all of
the other entries were engineering
features like how many players were in
the box how close was the nearest
Defender when they got the ball
the CNN architecture blew the other
entries out of the water in terms of its
predictive performance
and what we found was that architecture
was very useful in all of these
situations so we keep going back to the
CNN and the pooling technique because it
matches the intuition of the problem
if you have every if you have the
locates of every player relative to
everyone else then you can measure an
expectation of of yards gained
so let's take this example
in this example you'll you'll see
Raiders running back Josh Jacobs get a
handoff around the 35-yard line and the
line of scrimmage is at the 30. now the
question we're asking the model is how
many yards will this running back gain
on the play
so let's BR let's show the moment that
we are running inference so we have the
dots and the locations of every player
when they receive the ball so what we're
going to do is we're going to make a
prediction
we're going to expect three yards a
three yard gain so he gains three yards
past the 30. so we expect him to get
right to about the 27 yard line if you
can see that on that on that field
he actually
gained 30 yards on the play so you can
see on the right
how many Defenders he has to evade to
create this touchdown play now on the
stat sheet it's going to look like a
27-yard touchdown or a 30-yard touchdown
but when we evaluate how many yards the
average Runner would gain in that
situation we find that he outperforms
expectation by 27 yards
not only can we find the estimate of the
expected yardage number we can also
expect we can also predict the odds of a
first down the odds of a touchdown and
what this does is it creates significant
contextual features contextual stats
that more exemplifies what happened on
the field
our next model I'm going to talk about
is receiver route classification so what
route type did a receiver run on a given
play
so as you can see this was another
derivative of the big datable
Nathan sturkin who's now a data
scientist with the Cleveland Browns won
the competition and only a less than a
year later was hired by the Browns
he came up with a combination of a CNN
and lstm model that takes the player
locate data of each eligible receiver
and predicts one of 15 groups if you're
a wideout 11 10 10 white out routes and
if you're in the backfield five backfill
routes and what we did is we created a
prediction for what route did you run
out of those labels and now now we're
able to do a lot of splits you could say
of what route a receiver ran
on the right you'll see a diagram of all
of the route types for a wide receiver
and you can see the archetype of the
player paths over that time so what we
did is we take the moment of snap to
either the end of the pass or 4.6
seconds because anything beyond that
they're running around like a backyard
play and we're able to use that time
span for each individual player what
route did you run
now we're going to go into coverage
classification which is a little bit
similar to Route recognition but at the
team level
so what coverage type did a team run on
defense
as you can see on the right Tom Bliss
who's in the crowd today spoke last year
at the New York art conference he
created the Baseline model that became
our coverage classification model so
thank you Tom
what we used was a CNN or CNN attention
model and we took the temporal locates
of every player on defense from the snap
to our 4.5 second 4.6 seconds
and we also took the relative
positioning of all players relative to
all other players as a taking that from
the pooling Technique we learned from
expected yards
we were able to classify eight different
types so whether it was cover zero cover
one cover two which are man coverage and
then you also have cover two cover three
cover four cover six and which are Zone
coverage
on the right is a diagram of those man
coverage or the uh the first four
coverage types so the top left is going
to be cover zero man you can see that
everybody has a is responsible for a
play for an eligible receiver cover one
man you're going to see a deep a safety
who's patrolling the middle of the field
now you can imagine that the movements
of the players will be representative of
the play call and so that's why we can
take the play level player tracking data
take manual labels of saying that
they're in cover one cover two and be
able to train a model to find those
those uh those patterns to identify
those coverages
this is what the CNN looks like so
there's a lot of layers that went into
it and we use a self-attention model uh
in this case that that proved to be the
most uh compelling predictions
win probability what's the odds of a
team winning the game at any moment in
the game
so this is an XG boost model uh it we
found that engineering features was
important here so we looked at the score
differential the time remaining how many
timeouts were left we looked at how uh
the quality of the team so we have a
measure of you know if the if the Chiefs
and Patrick Mahomes are playing the
top the Buccaneers without Tom Brady
that line is the the team strength is
going to be indicative uh within this
model
so our Target output is one is a win
zero is a loss and over time the game
you can see the win probability
fluctuate for every play
on the right you'll see the a image of
the Minnesota Vikings historical
comeback last season where they were
down 33 points in the second half and
came back to win
their their win probability and they
excuse me
their win probability in that game got
to as low as 0.4 percent
it was the second lowest win probability
comeback of any game in the next gen SAS
era so we're able to quantify the
significance the context Behind these
crazy comebacks
that's a wrap on all of the models that
I was here to talk about today
I was I came here to talk about the many
and only had time to talk about few if
you have any questions please I'll be
around all uh during these two days and
happy to answer any more details of any
of the models I talked about today
I encourage you to if you're a Twitter
user to follow the next gen stats
Twitter account we are hot and heavy
during the football season with a ton of
the visualizations that you saw in
today's presentation you can follow me
on Twitter but mostly I I like to
consider myself the ghost writer of next
gen stats so that should be enough
or you can follow us on Instagram if you
prefer that
thank you